the
surface level campaign for president is
Biden versus Trump but the shadow
campaign is Newsom versus DeSantis
Newsom thinks that DeSantis is going to
be the nominee he's not taking the fight
to Trump he's taking it to DeSantis and
it could be Biden and Donald Trump are
relatively up there in age Trump seems
like a young vibrant man Biden does not
but there's still both a little bit long
in the tooth and the lips are trying to
lock up Trump in three different places
they'll try to get him in New York
they'll try to get him in DC they'll try
to get him in Georgia and so this is the
shadow campaign and we're still so far
out that it could happen